متكامل يجمع بين العمل السياسي
والدبلوماسي والنهوض بالتنميه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والبشريه للمنطقه
وفي هذا الاطار يندرج البرنامج الثانوي
الخاص بالاقاليم الجنوبيه الذي تم توقيعه
تحت رئاستنا في العيون في نوفمبر 2015
وهو برنامج تموح يستجيب
انشقالاته وتطلعات سكان الاقاليم الجنوبيه
وتتحمل السلطات المحليه والمنتخبه
مسؤوليه الاشراف على تنزيل مشاريعه
اليوم وبعد مرور حوالي سبع سنوات على
اطلاقه
فان تسمين النتائج الايجابيه
التي تم تحقيقها حيث بلغت نسبه الالتزام
حواله 80% من مشروع الغلاف المالي المخصص
فقد تم انجاز طريق السريع
تيزنيت الدخله الذي بلغ مرحله الاخيره
شبكات الاتصال
فما تم الانتهاء من انجاز محطات الطاقه
وفي المجال فلاحي
اسد من 6000 هكتار بالداخله
وضعها على الاشاره الفلاحين الشباب من
ابناء منطقه
وتالف معظم المشاريع المبرمجه في قطاعات
الفوسفات والماء
والثقافي عده انجازات في مجال الصحه
والتعليم
[موسيقى]
وفي هذا السياق المطبوع بروح المسؤوليه
الوطنيه
الخاص الى مواصله النهوض بالاستثمار
المنتج بهذه الاقاليم في المشاريع ذات
التابع الاجتماعي
كما ندعو لفت افاق جديد امام الديناميه
التي تعرفها اقاليمنا الجنوبيه
والطاقه المتجدده
شعبيه العزيز
لقد شكرت الصحراء المغربيه
من المغرب
وهو توجه ينسجم مع طبيعه طبيعه العلاقات
المتميزه التي تجمع المغرب بدون قارتنا
الافريقيه التي نحرص على تاسيسها لما يخدم
يخدم مصالح المشتركه للشعوب من الشقيقه
فخامه السيد محمد بخاري رئيس جمهوريه
نيجيريا الفدراليه
المغرب 2016
مذكره التفاهم الموقعه مؤخرا بالرباط
مجموعه الاقتصاديه دول غرب افريقيا
واننا نريده مشروع استراتيجي لفائده منطقه
غرب افريقيا كلها التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
اكثر من 440 مليون نسبه
وذلك لمن يوفر من فرص وطمانات في مجال
الامن التقى والتنميه الاقتصاديه
والصناعيه والاجتماعيه بالنسبه للدول 15
المجموعه الاقتصاديه افريقيا اضافه الى
موريتانيا والمغرب
انه مشروع من اجل السلام
والاندماج اقتصاد الافريقي والتنميه
المشتركه مشروع من اجل الحاضر والاجزال
القادمه
وبالنظر للبعد القاري لانبوب الغاز لجاي
المغرب فاننا نعتبره ايضا مشروعا مايكل
يربط بين افريقيا واوروبا
سات
في المساهمه الفعليه في انجازه
العمل بشكل وثيقه
في اقرب الاذان
لم يجدد الفتاح هنا على جميع اشكال اشتراك
المفيده من اجل انجاز هذا المشروع
الافريقي الكبير سامي العزيز اين الوفاء
لروحي المسيره الخضراء
خالد اذا طلب مواصله التعبئه من اجل
الدفاع عن وحده الوطن وتعزيز تقدمه
وارتباطه بعنقه الافريقي وهي مناسبه
مناسبه للترحم على روحي
جلاله الملك الحسن الثاني اكرم الله مثواه
والارواح كل الشهداء
كمان وجه تحيه اشاده وتقدير للقوات للقوات
المسلحه الملكيه والامن الوطني والدرك
الملكي والاداره الترابيه والكويت
المساعده والوقايه المدنيه على تفانيهم
تحت قيادتنا في الدفاع عن وحده الوطن
وامنه واستقراره والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تعالى وبركاته